add the blue and pink expressions to  create another expression and be sure to  combine like terms let me get the  scratch pad out here so we need to we  need to add this 6y plus 2 in blue so  we're going to add 6 y  plus 2 and we're going to add it to  negative 2 3 minus y  so we're going to add to negative 2 3  minus y so first let's add all the y  terms if we have 6 of something and i'm  going to subtract 1 of that something or  6 6ys minus 1y you could do this  literally as 1y i'm going to be left  with 5ys  and then i have 2 minus 2 thirds and  let's solve that right over here so 2  minus 2 thirds 2. let me write this 2  minus 2 thirds is the same thing as 2  can be rewritten as 6 thirds 6 divided  by 3 is 2  minus 2 3 which equals four thirds  so two minus two thirds is four thirds  so this is equal to five y  plus four thirds now let's actually  input that in to make sure we got it  right  five y  plus four over three and you see it  interpreted it properly  we got it right